what is going to happen in January of
2025
if a Democrat wins the November 2024
presidential election and the
Republicans try it again they try to
steal an election again but this time
they're better prepared and we aren't
any more prepared what would that
actually be like it's not crazy to be
thinking of this because there is now a
precedent they tried to steal the
election they became violent to try to
keep the loser that they supported in
power
how are we going to be ready in January
of 2025.
part of it has to do with who we vote
for this November if people like Doug
mastriano win and become governor of
Pennsylvania he will try to steal
Pennsylvania's electoral votes from the
Democrat to give them to the Republican
if a Democrat wins in Pennsylvania in
2024 so part of it has to happen now but
I'm concerned that people like Kamala
Harris aren't taking this seriously
enough and we're going to look at that
video in a moment first I want to tell
you about our sponsor policy genius
mortgage payments private student loans
other debt they don't disappear if
something happens to you a life
insurance policy can provide your loved
ones with financial protection
inflation's driving up prices for just
about everything life insurance rates
are actually down and since life
insurance often gets more expensive as
you age it's better to do it sooner
policy genius is the insurance
Marketplace that makes it easy to
compare quotes from Top insurance
companies all in one place listen I
don't I don't like this stuff I really
don't
but there are times when it's the right
thing to do I have a daughter now these
are things that I have to think about
and since 2014 policy genius has helped
over 30 million people shop for
insurance and has placed over 150
billion dollars in coverage you could
save 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius
options start at 17 bucks a month for
half a million dollars of coverage click
the link in the description go to
policygenius.com
davidpackman show to get free life
insurance quotes and see what you could
save I'm gonna play a video clip for you
here
does Kamala Harris sound
worried enough
about what Republicans might do
in 2025. I think the answer is no look
at this uh if you thought through the
scenarios that you might face on January
6 2025
not at all no I mean well listen uh what
have I thought about I have thought
about the fact that right now we have an
election in less than two months
and if we're going to look at timelines
that's one of the the most immediate
timelines I know but I mean have you
thought about how you might handle
certification that did not reflect the
outcome of the popular vote in the state
I haven't gotten to that point yet I I
have to believe that um
that the United States Congress and all
people who have taken an oath to defend
our democracy will ensure
and we'll stand up against anyone who
tries to
um
to destroy or circumvent it's a lot of
confidence in pretty horrible people the
rules and the practices and procedures
that we've had in place that have
allowed a peaceful transfer of power
since the Inception of our nation and
the founding of our nation and
getting back to the ultimate point
that is
um that is what we're talking about when
we think about January 6th
we have always had
peaceful transfer power in our nation no
matter our differences no matter how
we've been in campaigns can we say that
now
well certainly we oh we were at on the
verge of having a very different outcome
all right so listen I'm not expecting
Kamala Harris to tell us exactly what
they're planning to do to prevent the
loser from becoming the president I
don't expect her to give us all the
details but it would Inspire more
confidence if she were to say
we are taking this extremely seriously
after what happened on January 6th
whoever actually wins should be the next
president
whether it's a democrat or a republican
we can never elect what happened January
6th it got too close
and it can't even get that close again
so we are working a lot on this and she
doesn't have to give us the specifics my
instinct is
she I mean she she literally laughed it
off at the beginning my instinct is
they're not taking this seriously enough
yet and I hope that they will let me
know what you think in the comments